We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite-sized pieces
for your inspiration
and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is
King of Random Rewind
10. FLOATING COINS
9. TAB TENSIONER
8. THERMITE GRILL
7. FLOATING WITH SF6
6. FLAMMABLE BUBBLES
5. FANCY CROWN NAPKIN
4. LN2 ROCKET LAUNCHER
3. TOILET PRANK
2. CEREAL BLOWGUN
1. COPYING A RECORD
Hey guys, Grant here.
Hope you enjoyed this compilation.
If you would like
to see another one,
just click right up there.
If you want to see another video
that's randomly selected for you,
click down there.
And if you're not
already a subscriber,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
See you in the next video.